manchmal gibt es nur noch die
möglichkeit dann über die luft mit der
rettung zu beginnen mit drohnen wird
sich ein bild gemacht und dann mit
hubschraubern versucht die menschen zu
retten und genau aus ahrweiler stammen
diese aufnahmen die wir wiederum von
unserem helikopter machen konnten wir
haben uns hier mit bild live unser
kollege jörn böcker hat sich in die luft
begeben und konnte dann diese
spektakulären aufnahmen mitbringen wie
die helikopter menschen aus ihren
häusern heraus holen die dort
stundenlang ausgeharrt haben
das schwierige ist auch die
lokalisierung wo sind die menschen wie
kommen wir da runter dann werden wir
helfer herabgelassen und greifen sich
jemanden und da sehen wir schon die
menschen wir stehen da auf dem vordach
ihres hauses und warten darauf dass sie
rettete sich zu ihnen ab sein damit sie
dann über den luftweg gerettet werden
können hier kommt der retter an endlich
hier sehen wir drei menschen stehen auf
dem vordach der starke wind durch den
helikopter über ihnen bläschen ins
gesicht aber der ist der retter endlich
ist jemand da darüber liegt der
helikopter sind aufnahmen die konnten
wir und da als die rettung dort findet
sie statt dort werden die menschen nach
oben gezogen im hintergrund da hat man
gerade gesehen die wassermassen wie
weiter noch strömen und strömen mit
einer kraft und danke der flug auch
schon los menschen werden nach oben
gezogen
hier sehen wir das nochmal spektakuläre
aufnahmen der wind ist so stark sie sich
hier wie sich die menschen da festhalten
am haus ist der erste nach oben gezogen
wird müssen sich die anderen menschen
die noch warten darauf dass sie abgeholt
werden würde ich am haus festkrallen
weil der wind die rotoren dermaßen stark
ist und dann dann kommen sie dann in
sicherheit endlich in sicherheit weg von
den wassermassen und da kommt auch schon
der zweite hubschrauber die zweite hilfe
aus der luft ist endlich da die menschen
unten wir stehen auf ihrem vordach und
während der erste hubschrauber voll
beladen abdreht kommt schon der zweite
an
und versucht den menschen dort zu helfen
sie nach oben zu ziehen weg aus diesem
hochwassergebiet wir sind bild und wie
ihr liefert dir deine news auf youtube
zum nächsten video kommst du hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren